welcome back to new rockstars this is a
big question the show that gives you too
much information about that jolly fella
who sees you when you're sleeping
who knows when you're awake who knows
when you've been bad or good or your
sith lord dad's mistake
oh that's right the all-knowing santa
claus of the star wars universe is
an astromech droid who will outlive all
of us and we'll tell the tale
hey happy life day everybody i'm eric
foss with me today it's tommy bechtold
hey man how you doing hey thank the
maker thank the maker for this joyous
life day i've
just removed my virtual reality headset
where i was watching some wookie erotica
uh it's really been a special star wars
christmas for me it's really wonderful
see the wookie erotica i get into are
episodes of wookie leaks
ah yes well that is erotica for me as
well
for somebody it is yes i've been told oh
well speaking of wikileaks the
mandalorian season two has
wrapped up what a wild ride that was and
i gotta say this season revealed a lot
of
interesting secrets about the star wars
timeline re-contextualizing what we
thought we knew
but no character embodies that theme
more than our little r2d2 the astromech
droid
who has been there for everything he
knows all kinds of horrifying truths
about this
galaxy but he says nothing to nobody he
is essentially the cold war era spy
whose head is filled with so many
secrets that he just eventually cracks
up and they've got to send matthew
reeves and carry russell out to take him
out
yes or two he's gonna overload so what
is our what's our big question this week
so eric my question for you is what did
r2d2 know
and when did he know it what was his
involvement with watergate
the lights are off and they must be
looking for a fuse box or something
because in flashlights
they're keeping me awake yes who does
number two work for
well r2 uh the more we look into the
star wars universe
knows pretty much everything he and
c-3po opened the series as the focal
characters of a new hope and they have
appeared in
all nine chapters of the skywalker saga
as well as rogue one but
unlike c-3po r2 has never had
the memory wiped 3po did more than once
c-3po is definitely the guy who does too
much acid in that crew like he's the one
that's like oh he's been there for
everything but he doesn't remember much
of it
yeah you can't trust him what happened
there at 3po he's like i don't
remember we were listening to some great
tunes if i recall
there was lots of colors lots of colors
and what's crazy about r2 during his
time
he has accompanied a ton of crucial
historical figures
was there in the background uh
witnessing a ton of historical moments
that no one else did he was essentially
in all the rooms where all of it
happened
tommy let's break down specifically the
craziest things that r2d2
knew when no one else really knew it
starting with phantom menace r2d2 knew
padme was using a decoy handmaiden to
pose
as queen amidala in that movie remember
artu's first
chronological appearance was as just a
mere astromech droid
on that ship that saved amidala's royal
cruiser as it was escaping the naboo
blockade amidala
personally thanked the droid but then
later at night we'll have well at night
it's in space
sleep time and space she's really
nice that doesn't make any sense
everyone else is asleep including jar
jar but r2 was in that room and was
alert as
padme snuck in to receive royal
correspondence from their advisors
so that must mean that r2 knew something
was up there and then later
when padme revealed herself to boss nas
as the true monarch
r2 was in frame and doesn't do any head
spinning he
knew he's like damn right i told you i
put this on my tumbler
two weeks ago no likes no clout
all right next thing that's pretty crazy
and i think everyone knows is r2d2 knew
that padme and anakin wasn't
yeah before 3po knew at least because in
attack of the clones
padme of course went home to naboo
accompanied by anakin and
r2 r2 was there so and how he can go up
and down stairs while he was there
was there the whole time while they were
flirting they pretty much made him watch
thomas yes i don't think
maid has anything to do with it r2 is a
dirty filthy scumbag
he was like mind if i hang out lit a
cigarette and just hung in there
padme's like we gotta stop floating
pairs to each other r2 keeps giving me
this weird look
r2 was the original dog who likes to
watch he's just calmed by it
get down from there you get too good of
a view of things wait why is he looking
into the mirror
this is weird that's why he has those
rocket propulsions
he wants to get a weird drone oh my god
what a creep
cancel r2d2 cancel r2
um and then that brings us of course to
the next big bombshell r2d2 knew that
padme and anakin were secretly
wed and both 3po and r2 were present at
that secret wedding ceremony
why you know for visual poetry for
closing images of movies again it's like
poetry so if they rhyme
but why did they have those droids there
maybe they wanted to have some witnesses
to be like yes i know these two
i know how wrong it is can can droids
sign documentation as witnesses in the
in the world of star wars like could
c-3po be the witness to that wedding i
wonder that that's a big question with
inside of a question that is a future
big question can
androids be notaries we have to ask like
dave fellonio only he can make that
decision now
now this is the saddest detail about
what r2d2 knew
r2d2 had a personal friendship with
anakin skywalker between attack of the
clones and revenge of the sith
because in the revenge of the sith
novelization c-3po and r2d2
they had this little interesting chat
after anakin becomes vader and is on his
way to
ransack the the jedi temple 3po asks r2
what is going on with anakin
and r2 responds you know because c-3po
can understand what he says
translates to i don't know anakin
doesn't talk to me anymore
[Music]
and why it's heartbreaking is it means
anakin used to talk to him all the time
yeah buddies like just imagine anakin
probably told r2 things that he couldn't
divulge to anyone else to obi-wan to
padme
it's just like his buddy hanging out in
the back of his starfighter as you know
he's piloting alone in space for hours
and hours
artus is one confidant they even like
give evidence of this at one point mace
windu scolds anakin for encouraging
individuality in his droid and
it's like well you know this is my only
friend and friend's gone
leave me alone so sad and r2d2 is aware
of it
it's not just like oh the human doesn't
yell at me as much
it's like oh this friend is gone it's
like when you stop playing with your
family dog
or is that just something i did your dog
is fry's dog from futurama that's where
we get into some interesting stuff r2d2
knew that luke and leia were the
children of anakin
slash vader and padme both r2 and 3po
were present for those twins birth
and they were there the moment they were
named they knew those kids would be
named luke and leia
you'll remember of course the moment
bail organa and revenge of the sith
ordered that 3po's memory be wiped right
but
not r2 r2 made it through their memory
fully attacked i'm sure he wished
his mind could have been kidding at that
point yeah like i'd love to unsee this
i don't like sand
[Music]
no it would be great to not know any of
this happened
hell yeah and the novelization of
revenge of the sith again it makes this
knowledge
the revenge of the said novelization by
the way is a fascinating read
because that movie i think is under
appreciated the book goes into all this
an interesting character point of view
with dooku with with everybody
but there is a moment where 3po says oh
how lovely
his daughter is a child of master anakin
and senator amidala he explained to r2d2
i can hardly wait to tell her all about
her parents i'm sure she would be very
proud
and then senator organist said at the
protocol droid's mind white
so that means that when leia recorded
the message for obi-wan on the tantive
four
r2 knew in that moment that leia was the
daughter of darth vader the guy who just
took over this
oh man wow he didn't say anything what a
good secret keeper i would have been
like hey cool message you want to know
something crazy
that guy is your dad daddy that's your
dad he's your father
that astronaut that's your dad yes or
that salesman
mama that salesman's on tv hijacking the
tanta four
now uh when we get to just some military
plans r2d2 knew
about the rogue one crew's sacrifice to
attain the death star plans that leia
would later
give him and what exactly those
schematics meant to the cause because
in rogue one r2 and 3po were in that
hangar
with an earshot right when bail organa
ordered captain antilles to attend the
battle of scarif with the tanaford to
intercept those stolen plants
so they knew what the rogue one crew was
doing they
knew that whole heartbreak when that
happened which is tragic these things
know everything it's sad it's just
horrible merry christmas
merry christmas everyone now here's a
fun detail that i just realized that
r2d2 knew how to navigate in tatooine in
a new hope because he had been there
before so
when their escape pod crash lands three
po bickers with he's like you don't know
where you're going and she's like shut
up i know where i'm going
it's because as an episode of clone wars
tells us
r2 had previously visited tatooine and
that whole plot to save road of the hut
so
archie's like yeah i know where i'm
going i know this dune plant i'm good
don't worry about me
now the big controversial one is with
luke being vader's son r2d2
knew teenage luke was the son of darth
vader did not tell him
or even contradict obi-wan when obi-wan
lied or
you know told luke the truth from a
certain point of view
now when the jawas sold r2 to uncle owen
and luke it is possible that r2
in that moment did not know who luke was
i don't know if he knew the the lars
farm was where luke ended up
but when luke met obi-wan
r2 had to put two and two together at
that point i mean we did see that poor
little guy
tip over and faint
so maybe that's what that was about r2
has certainly been assigned a lot of
emotions and feelings i wonder if he
has a reverence and respect for obi wan
that he's like
if he's lying he's lying for a good
reason and it's
beyond me to contradict him in this
moment for sure
and there's other interpretations that
explain that maybe r2 had this owner's
protection protocol system that
prevented him
from telling his owner luke at that
point anything that might bring him harm
and in that case you could argue telling
luke that his father murdered his mother
killed a bunch of kids in a school he
became a cyborg who uses dark magic to
commit war crimes
maybe that would have led luke to
approach his father before he was ready
to confront him
it certainly would be i mean he'd send a
text he definitely sent a text hey just
heard about your past
not interested in meeting up i mean i
think the whole star wars universe
decided that luke's obliviousness
was kind of what protected him from
vader right he didn't know he was
important and that's why he didn't think
to ever leave the farm home and it's
also kind of fun to think about in the
trench run
on the death star r2 is accompanying
luke in his you know x-wing as
vader was pursuing that droid must have
been aware that his former master anakin
was the real father of his new master
and was now gunning him down
that must have been insane to process
this is exactly like when adam banks had
to play for the mighty ducks instead of
the hawks
he was playing against his old friends
he knew he knew who they were
and he didn't care he still triple
decked all the way to the goal
that's why you need banks they got banks
back for d2 they got over d
doesn't he come back to the ducks and d1
he stays with the ducks the whole time
he's
because redistricting they redistrict
him too that's right
isn't that what they call it is that a
slur i feel like maybe that's a
minnesota slur cake eater you're a moose
dragger
okay this is kind of the creepy one
because you're right r2d2 is kind of a
creep he
knew that luke and leia were seated yeah
he did he encouraged it he was there for
the birth he was with him on the death
star when the brother and sister
reunited he didn't say anything
and then on ha and the empire strikes
back when leia kisses luke
he just watches he knows how bad stuff
it is
doesn't react at all except if you
rewatch that scene he lets out
just the subtlest misablest
excuses he just does the pornhub sound
dude your roommate knows what that sound
is
that's right really clearly that's uh r2
letting out a scream for help he's just
like help
no god i can't they shouldn't be doing
this and uh while we're staying in
empire uh r2d2 previously knew yoda so
when
luke and r2 arrive on dagobah in empire
r2 gets annoyed with yoda they get a
little fight
but in clone wars this was years before
that moment chronologically
r2 accompanied yoda on a trip to dagobah
the same swamp planet when yoda was
seeking answers from the force
so when they were fighting an empire r2
must have just been annoyed that yoda
had turned into this crazy old hermit
who kept pestering him
come on you know me [ __ ] still trying
to dig in my drawers
now he might have just wanted yoda to
like cut to the chase to stop goofing
around and tell luke the truth because
you know r2 can't tell him
just tell him stop moving around and
then jumping ahead to the return of the
jedi
r2d2 knew the full details of luke's
over-complicated rescue slash
escape plan from jabba to 3po
ended up in jabba's possession that was
just step one of luke's weird multi-step
plan
that plan was followed by leia
disguising herself as a bounty hunter
bringing in chewie to thaw
out han but uh then they got captured
and then
luke got himself captured all of this
was just set up so that r2 whom
luke pre-loaded with a hidden lightsaber
could alley-oop the weapon to him at the
right moment
r2 was sitting on that the whole
watching watching leia chained up in a
metal bikini he's like
this is just part of the plan part of
the way yeah this is great though he's a
cigarette again
he's like wow why is that droid always
smoking and then uh jumping ahead to the
sequel trilogy r2d2 knew about luke's
failure with ben solo in the new jedi
order he was there he was present with
lucas they watched the jedi temple burn
after ben's revolt uh r2 was so
tired tommy he just went into sleep mode
who could blame him this guy's earned a
good night's sleep i would go to sleep
too
after all of that and i'd never wake up
i'm just like never wake me up just let
me sleep forever yes
bb-8 woke him up when he had that
missing piece of the star map to utch
too so
whenever he's back in it but then even
more tragically r2d2 his final on our
list
r2d2 was the first to know leia died
yeah skywalker he sensed that leia was
weak as she was walking over to the bed
and then
she was trying to send her presents to
kylo and ray in their fight and then the
moment
leia's hand drops who's there to see it
who's the first one to be in that room
where it happened
r2d2 oh r2 he's seen so much
conclusion r2d2 watched the entire
skywalker family
suffer
and obliviously rush into weird plans
all kinds of danger
awkward incest situations but he was
powerless to stop any of it he was a
true elf on a shelf
he's like the watchers in the highlander
they can only observe
and never interfere well thank you r2
because without you
we wouldn't know what happened without
you the movies would be 45 minutes long
because
if you had spoken up i guess with you
but in another way
you could have ended all these conflicts
or at least gotten people to make
decisions that were
more intelligent but instead you just
let them do whatever you gave them free
will
in a way he's like god he gave them all
free will to make their own legacies and
destructive choices
and uh god sees you when you're sleeping
knows when you're awake oh yeah he does
and doesn't even bat again i put on a
show for god i don't put that in that's
gross
stunting for god he knows what that
sound is
we're going to keep this jingle jangle
jingling uh
with ring ting tingling too
we got a bite size question that we're
going to answer the best we can
in one bite of a santa claus our friend
a tripper on discord asks
how does santa claus deliver presents to
children all around the world in
a single night yes a tripper
from the football picks pool hey tripper
i recognize that name
hey tripper very helpful tommy and i are
gonna try to answer this together
because you're right even if santa who
does exist were to travel west with the
rotation of the earth as fast as he can
millions of households he would have to
hit would make it
impossible for someone like that to
visit every house in a single night yeah
but i think
tommy and i have some theories on how
he's no normal mortal
i'll go first eric santa is a spirit
a jolly ghost the laws of physics do not
apply to him
he himself is a cosmic specter but the
toys he brings
are tangible and real so well he wow is
not
corporal being per se the toys are real
the joy is real that makes them even
more powerful tommy if you think about
it if you strike him down
he's a force ghost he is a force ghost
yes
that's it but an even more powerful
force goes to isn't just in another
plane who you can communicate with he
can cross
over into the tangible realm and produce
toys that children's can still play with
that's incredible
he can cross over both worlds yeah he's
like the ghosts
in the field of dreams who can just go
back and forth over
the line he's like shoeless joe jackson
yeah do you think the people who
buy that farm are like do the ghosts
come with the corn
can we exercise the ghosts or is that
just the thing we have to have
if you build it he will come oh
hell no can we cut down the corn stalks
and sell them or are they going to
be rid with that one of the ghosts made
my daughter buy him cocaine
is that actually that wasn't a ghost
that was a drifter
but he was very pale andres is a
baseball player he's a ghost now
he did all the cocaine in one city okay
uh kids
theory too even if uh santa was a
speedster like
the flash or quicksilver santa could not
physically move faster than the speed of
light otherwise he would disintegrate
so i'm thinking maybe he can create a
warp
bubble around himself that allows him to
teleport
through space-time from one house to
another house
essentially creating a rift in
space-time a wormhole wrinkle in time
you bend you bend the sheet of paper and
you poke a hole through it that's what
santa does
you knock books off the shelf we've all
seen interstellar we get it
murph murph come on murph you can do
this huh smurf
decorate the dreamer that part is
shouldn't be that emotional and i cry
like a baby every time i watch it
because
because he's so worked up as an actor
that i'm like
it makes me emotional anyway point three
on our little dissertation what we know
as santa is
actually a company called santa society
of altruistic knicks throughout america
every neighborhood in the united states
has a different local santa
a representative of the santas if you
will this is the santa you see at the
mall or at santa's village
or the one who comes to your school or
the guy who comes home with your mom
after a friday night at the movies it
makes a little too much noise and you
come out into the hallway and you say
who are you and he goes go to bed kid
i'm santy claus
that guy papa tens of thousands of these
santas but only one jeff
and they're all oath swearing due paying
members of this proud union
their duties include present delivery
letter and gift list reading
and naughty and nice sorting their
payment is cookies
they elect a santa chairman every year
and there's lots of politics involved
this year i hear there's a disputed
election where one santa won't concede
well
he's invited the elves from certain
certifying boards and swing states
and uh maybe one might flip there's a
lot of uh goblin
lawsuits those goblins are grossing not
all over
i have another theory i think that over
the years
many of santa's elves might have just
grown older
and uh chubbier let themselves go why
weren't you
at health practice they began to look
like singing okay
just kind of like how married couples
start to look like each other
that's what happens with these elves who
none of these things can die they're all
immortal so they just as they get older
they start to look like santa's now he's
got like
hundreds thousands of these things a big
team of santa plus a thousand
and thousands of thousands of santa
looking elves and they all deliver the
gifts
in a fleet of slaves and then santa has
them all dressed up in identical santa
claus so that
no kid who happens to see them would
know which one is the true santa they
just all assume the real santas come to
their house
you sit on a throne of lies but because
santa's such a good guy
he always does a shift he always has an
undercover boss because each year
he he wants to do a different shift in a
different neighborhood and get to know
the whole world
i like that that's really nice option uh
five santa is like liberace and he
forces his lovers to get plastic surgery
to look just like him just kidding
that's not it
uh i just made that one up to see who's
paying attention
no number five santa is like zack morris
and can freeze time
but only on one night per year and not
to bully people the way zack used it
that's why you never see him actually
put the presents under the tree
the dilation is what accounts for the
tilt of the earth and the waning and
waxing day
length throughout the year it's all
those little time blips that's
that's what's making it happen if santa
didn't do this every christmas night
every day would be the same length
throughout the year so we actually owe
santa
for all those 4 30 it's dark outside
nights
that make me so depressed thanks santana
causes the seasons
the seasons don't cause santa it's kind
of like our theory about the night king
and game of thrones
yes that we thought like he came with
winter the winter is coming but no
his arrival is what brings winter with
him that's what santa is he's the night
king
and he's gonna be stabbed to death by a
little girl cindy lou who she's gonna
pull a real cool move
with a dagger candy canes
candy canes lick him in a spear and kill
your
enemies that's that's that's that's
that's that's that well
i think one of these must be the
plausible explanation i i don't i can't
think of any other
possibility in this that's got to be it
that's got to be true it's got to be one
of those yeah
all right we have time for one final
bark scrub
box of scraps christmas edition yay
i'm gonna let miss potts live
that's the opposite he's nice about it
all right what is it lay it on me
what is your favorite christmas memory
i'm gonna say my favorite kid christmas
memory
when i was five or six i desperately
wanted the ghostbusters firehouse
it was a toy that kenner made with the
ghostbusters toys and
i didn't think i was gonna get it
christmas had kind of come and gone
and then it showed up it got delivered
like right on christmas eve like it was
wow
it showed up like that night and it was
a christmas miracle for me
it's a christmas miracle i have a less
kind
christmas memory that i i like to
remember because it reminds me of who i
am and where i came from i
was 19 maybe 20. it's the christmas i
realized my family
is the mean family are the bad guys in
the world
i love my family don't get me wrong but
i realized i looked around
finally objectively at my family said
wow we're a bunch of jerks
so when i was yeah 19 or 20 i went out
for
like all the family was back in town for
the holidays and we uh i'm the youngest
of like
five siblings so everyone's older and
everyone came back in town we went out
to lunch somewhere
at like this restaurant it was like it
was like a diner or something like that
and we had a big table because there's a
ton of us and did not make reservations
and were kind of rowdy and my dad was
just in kind of a bad mood he was in a
crabby mood and was like
flagging down the server and the server
was like no
do not flag me everyone was just in kind
of like a snotty mood
and at one point my brother looks over
and someone at another table
was wearing one of those you know those
festive uh
antlers that you can wear oh yes it's
like kitty cat ears but they're antlers
people wear them during the holidays
they're so sweet my brother was kind of
like making fun of her like under his
breath
and then it went over to my sister's
show like i look at the antlers
look at this [ __ ] look at this
[ __ ]
and my dad goes what are you talking
about what the antlers
and the woman i did a half turn yes
and tommy 15 seconds later she took off
her
oh no you shaved you antler shamed her
we antler shame this poor happy birthday
woman
to be fair antlers aren't an indoor
choice for a restaurant you gotta take
those off when you sit down come on it's
like a baseball cap she sang the
national anthem with his antlers
she disrespected the flag i felt so bad
and in that moment
my heart broke and i was like oh where
the jerk and i saw myself i saw my whole
family like where the grinches we're the
scrooges
we're not the nice christmas families
we're the ones who snark at the other
christmas families in church for singing
christmas carols
[Music]
and this whole time i thought we were
cool and we were the heroes of the story
but no
no no no no we're the villains we're the
scots carcasses of the
christmas and i'm the little toady guy
i'm gonna tell my dad
i will always going forward try to be
the christmas saint i will try to be the
bob cratchit and not
the scrooge yeah going forward after
this well
happy holidays everyone kind happy
holidays from us at new rock stars to
you
we hope wherever you are you are staying
safe
and find a nice honey to shack up with
hell yeah
i'm gonna sleep with this thing
i like that you're inside it you have
been eaten by it and you're just
enjoying that it's digesting me
the the juices so warm finally
well thanks tommy uh for joining me this
episode it's been great to chat about
all this with you you can make sure to
follow tommy
tommy bechtold follow me at eavos follow
new rockstars send us your big questions
using the hashtag b questions subscribe
to this podcast feed
give us a nice rating and review
subscribe to rockstars here on youtube
hit that notification bell
because every time you do an angel gets
its wings and the boss family will shoot
it down from heaven
love it see you next time uh we'll be
back next week with
everything new rockstars got wrong this
year and we got
everything wrong oh god do i have to
participate in that
it's gonna be so but we're gonna need
you to chime in and thank god
tell us everything we got wrong all
right see everyone next week
[Music]
you